فاكد رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه غاليري جريمه صوف ان
روسيا الحديثه لم تعرف ابدا مثل هذا
المستوى والشده للعمليات العسكريه في
اشاره للحرب في اوكرانيا واشار جرش موف
الى ان روسيا وقواتها المسلحه اليوم تواجه
فعليا كل الغرب الجماعي تقريبا لافتا الى
ان روسيا لم تتخذ اي تدبيره للتعبئه
الجزئيه منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه وكشف
ان روسيا بدات بتعديل برامج تطوير القوات
المسلحه نظرا لتطلعات النيتو لتوسعه عبره
فنلندا والسويد واستخدام الاوكرانيا اداه
لشن حربنا ضد دروس
انه من اجل تحييد هذه التهديدات كلفت
القياده العليا للبلاد دي مهمه تعديل خطته
بناء وتطوير القوات المسلحه بموافقه
الرئيس بوت اوضح جرستيموس ان الخطه نصه
على انشاء منطقتي موسكو ولنغراد
العسكريهتين وتشكيلين ثلاث فرقا عسكريه في
مقاطعه هيرسون وزبروجيو وفيلقن عسكريا قرب
فنلندا
معنى من موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين درغامي
امين مرحبا بك معنا اذا
ما هي التفاصيل هذه الخطه واهميه ما يتم
الاعلان عنه الان
في الحقيقه محمد ما تحدث عنه رئيس هيئه
الاركان الروسيه فاليري جراسيمو الان اييه
هو نفس الخطه التي كانت القياده العسكريه
الروسيه قد اعلنت عنها
عندما عين جراسيموف قائدا للقوات الروسيه
المشتركه في اوكرانيا وذلك في تغيير عسكري
شمل عدد من القطاعات من بينها ما تحدث عنه
اليوم دراسه موضوع انشاء منطقتين عسكريتين
جديدتين في موسكو
اي سان بيترسبورج اضافه الى قوات عسكريه
في مقاطعه طيزه باروجا وخرسون وقربها
الحدود مع فنلندا جراسي موف وضع كل هذه
التغييرات والخططه العسكريه الجديده في
اطار مقالي انه تهديدات باتت تتعرض لها
روسيا بشكل متزايد من قبل الغرب وتحديدا
من قبل حلف شمال الاطلسيه الذي توسع همم
كثيرا في عند حدود روسيا الغربيه تحديدا
همم في همم فيلندا وطبعا السويد وهنا
الحديث ايضا عن خطر متنامي ومواجهه باتي
الروس يتحدثون عنها في علاونه الاخيره
بشكل متزايد بينهم وبين القوه الغربيه
مجتمعه وذلك طبعا همم خلال من خلال الدعم
الذي تقدمه الدول الغربيه لاوكرانيا
تصريحات روسيه كثيره خلال الفتره الاخيره
التي باتت تتحدث على ان الغرب انتقل من
مرحله الحرب الهجينه الى المواجهه
المباشره ومسكو ارسلت خلال الفتره الاخيره
ايضا تحضيرات من ان تتحول هذه المواجهه
الى حربله
هناك من حذر في روسيا على سبيل المثال متر
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي الى
مواجهه نوويه في حال مائده
من غير ما تروسيا على خساره حرب تقليديه
كما كان ميدفاديف قد قال الاسبوع الماضي
اذانا اليوم نحن امام تغييرات عسكريه
روسيه امام لا تشمل فقط الوضع على الحدود
او
بمحادات العمق الروسي همم عندما روسيا
كانت تتحدث عن تطوير جيشها قرب الحدود اي
في المقاطعات المجاوره الاوكرانيا الان
باتا الحديث عن زبروجه وخرسون على سبيل
المثال التي ضمتهم روسيا بحسب طبعا همم
الاستفتاء الذي نظم في سبتمبر الماضي لكن
ايضا هناك تغيرات اخرى تحدث عنها الدراسي
المتشمل همم القطاعات العسكريه تطوير
الجيش الصناعات الحربيه هو غيرها شكرا
جزيلا لك امين من موسكو